yep welcome round eight of the
candidates in London and again the
second round where I was personally at
the site being able to watch the games
yeah it's a great in spirit experience
to to watch to watch the games life and
being analyzed at on-site also by by the
players who often join after the games
it's really really nice and if you have
the chance to do with it the tournament
is really something I can heavily
recommend in fact I also met a couple of
viewers of the channel at the side who
yet very nice to to have some some
chela's supporters on site and getting
to know you are in person yeah well
let's um go to the games we had some
cards against aronia and today the yeah
the two favorites and cool leaders of
the tournament playing each other but
have a look at the game quite often
those heavyweight clashes are not so
great and unfortunately this wasn't one
of the most exciting games we have a
Catalan opening and it's the main line
Catalan with short castles and now
capture on c4 this is the absolute main
line of the opening and Carson goes for
Queen c2 which is normal a six and now
Queen C for a forum is the main
alternative which has the advantage
compared to Queen takes c4 that it keeps
more pieces on the board and somehow
this is a somewhat sharper game this is
what Aronian in fact played in some
games
but Carson took b5 coincident with be
seven and him the big parting of the
ways he played Bishop to d2 witches the
main try for an advantage in this
position it of course has been played
before numerous times and here we have
Bishop d6 a3 yeah this is the idea white
intends to play be form but Aronian
doesn't really care I placed Knight B to
d7 b form and now in this position um
he plays I'm a strong but maybe slightly
surprising move he plays rook to e7
which had which is the kind of move
would just played by a very strong
player a very weak player in this case
we know it's it's a very strong player
yeah rook moves of this kind sometimes
are weird and bad because what is the
rook doing there but here it has got a
very good and concrete idea black wants
to play Queen to a8 and this sets up
some pressure on the long diagonal also
with rook and queen on the fr there's a
five as a possibility well it continued
not c3 Queen to a8 and not to H form
yeah not to h4 is not a move that it's
too inspiring but what is white actually
doing in this position one additional
issue here is the move might be six
night to see form possibly white squares
are weakened and I don't really know
what White's big a DM is supposed to be
in this position
maybe rook to e1 something like this and
some maybe more
more testing but black has
just something like this and what is why
it's supposed to do now
yeah somehow it seems that all this is
not too great for white so cousins some
preparation really failed him
it's simply nothing for white he played
night to age for Aronian exchanged and
now played the simple but very strong
move c6 c 6x the B pond so that a5 is
the possibility and the thing is white
that doesn't have anything against this
idea and he actually needs to be careful
now to to keep this equal to have
something against this a5 IDM plate rook
c1 a 594 exchanging a couple of pieces
this is logical rook c8 because his six
was saying and now he played Knight to
f4 intending to get this piece back into
play but okay black of course just takes
him and if you now would take with the
pawn there's even located two and this
is already starting to get really
annoying for white
there's also Knight f65 coming so that's
not the way to go
he played Bishop takes before and now
black has a choice he can also take on
before and play okay for something like
this but the Aronian just went for c5
which simply exchanges everything Queen
here hang so you need to exchange Queens
now takes takes and it's simply a dead
position you can
look and quite it's quite funny that yes
yes ma'am
move 31 and you cannot draw in this
tournament before move 30 so in this
position they actually could have made a
draw but somehow they for whatever
reason played like ten more moves and
here it was agreed drawn so I'm a quite
disappointing game actually it's um look
at the times it was over in about one
and a half hours of course not great but
what can you do
it's simply Carson went for a very safe
opening with the Catalan Aronian had his
preparation finally completed and played
this strong rook a7 and queen to a8 and
after that it's simply nothing for what
um II on that level
a pretty pretty weak preparation my
white yeah because I mean what what can
you say I must be honest he want to
press a bit then this is simply not the
way to go
maybe maybe more with with eight a four
or something but this was simply a non
game and bit be comparable to his game
against Kramnik where there were also
was nothing with white he really needs
to win some black games in this
tournament and he did so far because
with white he didn't do didn't do so
much against the big guys so the same
all right so this ended in a draw the
next game I want to look at but only
briefly is Greece shocked against even
shocked and I will explain to you why I
don't look at it so deeply we had a
Sicilian defense and an open Sicilian in
fact he won sure played the very
surprising move g6 this is surprising
because it is actually a well-known fact
that
this should lead to a really big
advantage for white but we shook didn't
play it he spent a couple of minutes and
and didn't take this chance it was very
very weird to me that he didn't do it
the normal way to continue is something
like this and it's it's an excellent
position for white I don't really know
why I didn't do it Ted Bishop b3 and
after this we transposed to a regular
accelerated to dragon position the early
Queen a5 of course
intends to grab this pawn and use the
pin so on white is forced to play short
Castle it's not possible to get to this
long castle or hacking lines and this is
all very standard 95 now is slightly
uncommon news but certainly a good idea
there Diaz some if black plays it simple
and just takes like this then this kind
of structure is really a big advantage
for white as the 7th pawn is so weak and
white can just play normal pile up roofs
against the 7 pawn so here at the end is
also blacks King under under fire
so this exchange on d5 is really a bad
move rook e8 is fine by a bunch okay now
Bishop took on f6 and played c3 and I
think this looks like a slightly better
position for white it's not much but a
little bit he's got comfortable
development and good pieces in the
center and he's got this f4 f4 idea also
um he once you've played it didn't very
interesting fashion had 95 tending not
g4 for example I now grew shocked really
spent lots of time and at the end went
h3 he said in the press conference that
he spent his time mostly on calculating
F form nyjah form and then some very
very complicated variation
that frankly speaking I couldn't follow
he was rattling them off so quickly it's
I cannot reproduce this really but he
spent lots of time on this at the end he
settled for 83 after more than 30
minutes at least I have some idea now
what he spent 30 minutes on because
honestly I would have played 83 also in
this position but probably after 5
minutes and not 30 which only means that
I'm superficial and not digging deeply
he really showed some amazing stuff
after him for but alright let's say it
was it was very deep stuff I don't know
if it was amazing but he he spent lots
of time on this and look at the clocks
this is the fun thing they both have
spent like an hour after 30 moves even
shook now Queen a6 which is an
interesting idea sets side on d3 and now
night c2 again after after a while this
is an interesting move it prepares this
Bishop d4 idea and maybe intense night
before to d5 very interesting move 93 by
von Schuch and Queen f3 this is also an
interesting idea piling up here on f7
and I think it's almost forces blacks
replied like Bishop e6 and now Bishop
deform and in fact I think it's really
good
the well played game I mean it looks
very correct in a way I've got some more
exchanges Queen b6 and now rook a3 so it
looks like pretty much a normal game
white is maybe very very slightly more
comfortable he's got a bit of an idea of
the fr maybe can play b4 b5 and it's a
little bit of something I mean Gavin was
watching the game and in the after the
press conference he joined in the nanos
this room for a couple of minutes to
show some points of his game but also
look at the
other games and he said that White has a
little bit of something here but
probably not much and it's now the
reason why I am I don't want to spend
too much time on this look at the clocks
they both have like eight minutes and
now even Jacques was simply still
thinking long I mean if you look at this
look just look at the clock times which
are fairly accurate there's not much
happening on the board look at the clock
times two minutes you this is I simply
assembly don't understand what what this
person is what is doing I mean you need
to just move quicker here to stay in the
game I mean you cannot spend two minutes
when you have eight minutes left on on a
move like rook c8 I mean this is a
nothing move you can play it in 10
seconds and 92 and again he spent a
minute or what yeah a minute for
exchanging look at the clocks five
minutes four minutes three minutes 20 so
he kept spending a minute in a situation
well you simply need to move and a
couple of moves later yeah one minute
again one minute again and we we came to
a point where it was impossible to
simply make the time control now it is
11 moves in in one minute which if you
only know online chefs seems like an
eternity but it's a different situation
and over the board play it's it's it's
possible to make the moves but it's not
at all easy 14 seconds yeah we had a
situation where he had to move ten had
to make ten moves in him in 25 seconds
or something this is not entirely
correct here and he actually made manage
the times are not completely accurate
but he was like 25 seconds for four
really I don't know lots of move eight
moves or something and he saw
kept thinking I mean not like moving
instantly but thinking for a couple of
seconds and then move so at the end you
know how you already guessed it he after
this he over set the time again for the
third time in this tournament and I
really don't don't get what he's what
he's doing it's pretty pointless to play
if you lose on time I mean pretty much a
nothing position I mean white is
probably very very very slightly better
but it's it's really easy especially
after the Queen exchange to make a
couple of nothing moves and simply to go
over move 40 I mean just just stay in
this position let's say yeah let's say
you're worried about 95 okay then you
play Knight f6 and just stay I mean I
don't know it's really weird sometimes
what's what he's doing okay so grief
shook won this game which means he is on
50% again and yeah what what can you do
I mean if your opponent is is simply
willing to to commit suicide on the
clock then you just take the point and
say thank you okay and so two games left
and these were the more interesting
games today um let's go with the Raja of
Galvan game first we had another English
opening here this with 96 fairly popular
line that girl font already had played
before in this tournament against
Aronian going for this line before we
also have seen and this is what raja
baath played in fact those moves are
known from the carlton Kramnik game who
had cousin played Bishop f4 and didn't
get anything out of the opening the
maybe most combative move to to get a
fight going as a three which maybe it's
a bit
intuitive that a three should be the
most interesting move but probably it is
still the the most interesting to to try
this prevents any Bishop before counter
place and propose a capacity form later
so black plays a move like this you can
actually go in form so a three or some
is an interesting way to play here and
maybe the move that I would play myself
as wide a job before ever played the
moves g3 yeah g3 is some the Oder move
in this position and yet made me curious
what would happen now because this is a
line that I had analyzed no years ago
and always tried to make work for white
in a way that well I would like to play
this position it's not it's not bad for
white as it simply I never found a good
a good line that I personally like let's
see what happened it went along the
lines that I I was investigating years
ago Queen b6 this attacks the night so
white needs to move it and the line that
I looked at mostly years ago was Knight
b5 and the idea being to yeah to give
this check for for one thing and to
simply yeah put this night on a useful
active square it can um lead to very
sharp play after Knight e5 which attacks
the pawn and white has interesting ways
to play for example Bishop f4 is very
sharp but this didn't happen he played
Knight to b3 which is the the standard
way to to go about that 95 this is
blacks idea he wants to take the pawn
and provoke white to to somewhat
weakened the position the thing is how
do you protect this pawn you cannot
easily sacrifice it so he played ephone
protecting it and now we should be four
so this is blacks idea he's playing with
pieces Knight to e5 attacking c4 now the
bishop to pressurize the center so it's
a bit of a hyper modern approach why
term gains space in the center but black
had texted with pieces
Queenie - this looks a bit awkward but
the problem is before was hanging
because of the spin so no way to protect
it he could play em here but okay see
force is upon Queenie - is the only move
that not loses material d6 and now it's
White's move here move back then when I
analyze this I mostly try to make Bishop
d2 work but it doesn't seem to be so
great this was recently tried in a game
by a German top player Daniel Freedman
and former teammate of mind always funny
to see him play the big guys when we
played together in the Bundesliga years
ago yeah well he played a lot in
baden-baden just some weeks ago with
Bishop d2 but it didn't really lead to
much after quick a5 a4
rajamma place the the old way so to say
this is well known for years and for
kicking the night knight c6 Bishop III
so black took and retreated the Queen so
this is some popping up by force after
Bishop III so what is this position
White has got pawn weaknesses here it's
got a very bad structure on the Queen
side and what's the compensation well
you've got let's put this on the board
you've got two bishops which can be
potentially very good for what those
bishop pair or this bishop em and you
have some chances on the Kings side how
so let's say Blackwood Castle here which
is um no a normal move then white can
actually play for g4 g5 if he wants
let's say castles b6g for this kind of
position is some has been played
numerous times f5 and and white tries
for some some big attack on the on the
King side it doesn't have such a great
reputation to be honest for white
because okay you've got chances but you
also completely busted on the Queen side
it's questionable of this g4 stuff is
really good but in this position um
galvan played a slightly unusual move
but I guess this will change if the
other possibility could be that this
line is out of business now he played a
five and this is simple and strong chess
I mean just putting the pawn here means
that the g2 bishop will always buy it on
its own pawn it's simply a bad piece on
g2 and it's very simple and very very
convincing if you ask me this move the
only possible objection with this move
could be the move c4 to c5 and this is
what your job of plate if he
would not play this let's say he would
he would castle in this position then
black would have played a it'd be six
and stopping c5 and now you are in a
situation which is a bit comparable to
the one I put on the board earlier with
with ecigs but now with the pawn on e5
there's even no way white can play e4 e5
and this position is simply good for
black with Bishop e6 coming and
attacking in the pawn on c4 this is
viral job of plate c5 and he mentioned
in the press conference that he actually
had looked at this line at some point
I'm not sure if he did so right before
the game it's possible because frankly
speaking you could easily arrive at this
position gelfand has played this this
stuff for forms a number of times so he
could anticipate this position he said
Rajah who said that he anticipated a
line that he had analyzed with an
engines was D takes e5 Bishop c5 and
takes on a form after this there is
Queen d2 takes g3 and long castles which
looks frankly speaking completely insane
and the even more insane factors that
the computer wants to play and here
takes on h2 and assesses this position
as completely equal because of Bishop
here Queen b6 Bishop c5 and this strange
strange kind of repetition so um okay
this is of course complete nonsense
the repetition I mean white can can play
numerous other things but this whole
line is is completely completely crazy
but black captures everything right to
the pawn on h2 and he casted long even
and white attacking blacks King which is
stuck in the center so what do we add
line this is what the job of somehow had
to had looked at before but now we can
see a difference in
yeah and I don't know how to call it in
maybe chess yeah approach to the game or
whatever I mean Galvan just played here
b6 which she had prepared you can also
see it from the time spent and this is
simply a good move simple and good chess
it questions a spawn where do you want
to go what needs to take now it's no way
he can allow black taking on c5 and the
thing is well you cannot really take
here as a takes B immediately allows
this Bishop a6 move and black simply has
a fine position after that at first you
might think okay b6 isn't so great okay
it isn't but those pieces are those
pawns are weak and this Knight is
especially bad it can never go anywhere
active can only drop back taking on b6
really as it's not looking like like a
good option he took on d6 after which
okay the Queen just recaptured
now castles castles and now have a look
at this position White has really an
awful night on b3 it doesn't control
anything and he's got the porn
weaknesses and this this basically means
that blacks tasked now is some
relatively easy he knows what to do and
this is the difference for white it's
not so easy to determine what what you
should play black tries to activate
pieces and directing them against the
weaknesses like on e4 C 3 a 2 and what
is white doing he's got yeah it's got
two bishops but what use are the bishops
if they placed like this one here just
biting on the for porn in fact here I'm
a suggestion that her job of from came
up with at the press conference was
taking only five
maybe this is really an interesting idea
a 95 and now 90 form the big difference
to the game is that this night is
actually playing and yeah playing really
good in the center of the board not
standing on b3m and being not able to
move at all
however it is from structure point of
view it's it's a disaster
White has got for porn Islands against 2
which means all kinds of end games would
be terrible and railroad job was a job
of said it himself in the press
conference this is kind of a yam it's
not the thing you you really aim for
it's just some sort of yeah last-ditch
Adam to attempt to to get something
that's not great yeah well he played f5
which I must admit um at first looked
really dangerous to me like g4 g5 isn't
this dangerous for black but in fact it
it doesn't materialize girl font here
could have played Queen a3 immediately
intending Bishop to a6 and this is maybe
even stronger than what he played which
was good but maybe this was even
stronger let's focus on the game which
saw a similar idea rook t8 rook t1 and
Queen a3 intending Bishop a6 and
activating this bishop of course is huge
for blackened simply doesn't have any
future on ciated must go to a6 and here
it took on the aid was check night
recaptures and now Bishop to g5 tried to
maybe a damaged black structure bit or
get some counter play on the kingside
get from played Bishop a6 as planned
Queen moved and Queen to e7 so the Queen
really did his job her job on a3 to
allow Bishop a say
now you can return and coordinate the
pieces and as mentioned it is much
easier for black to continue just go
here maybe here attacking a form rook to
the aid exchange one pair of rooks it's
really easy to do and what is white
doing in the meantime I think white
already is is in trouble I mean it feels
like you should be able to defend better
than then what job of did but if even if
you look at it with an engine with which
I did obviously it doesn't really it's
so obvious how to how to how to defend
this better roopd one night b7 Bishop f3
probably intending to exchange this
bishop or maybe on a good day activated
yeah black gets rid of one pair of Hoops
and now he has exchanged all those
pieces that you don't need for attacking
of those pieces rooks are not so
responds rooks are not so great for that
so get rid of them and now use the
Knights the Queen the bishop to attack
the the pawn weakness here we go
and if I was saying yeah Java decided to
get rid one of the Knights but it didn't
really help get font recaptured with the
pawn he could have taken with the Queen
but this slows down the play a bit I
mean you want to activate your Queen and
you simply take much longer if you
recapture with the Queen and also this
has the advantage that you don't need to
worry about the back rank now black can
always play King to g7 it's a good move
simply also protecting you 5
Queen here and coincident dad Queen c7
is very strong it has got various ideas
this is the most and
dangerous one it with made on f1 quite
funny and it also brings other ideas
into the game night to be five for
example attacking c3 or just queen c6
attacking me 426 is probably better the
night b5 which looks like self-penned
after Bishop e2
yeah Queen c7 this is really strong and
your job off with the time ticking down
he played now the muth a4 which intends
to get some kind of activity em but this
in fact allows a very strong reply by
galvan which she found played Queen d7
this is very rare very strong it takes
the pawn and threatens Knight f5 and 94
because d1 Bishop is hanging and yeah
this is now really completely lost why
it has no move to to cover all this he
played a 5 and now 90 form instead Queen
b5 the immediate could be 5 was also
very strong threatening made and white
he is also no move but this was very
strong awesome yeah we secured the
bishop but now just this move with the
maid idea White has only one possible
way to it to cover that you play the
Queen here but now 95 and now notice the
King Queen 8 you just play King g7 and
it's nothing
learn nuances like this that really help
if you are able to spot that takes with
the pawn is stronger so I'm yeah Queen a
checkers is no move
played queen here and after B takes a
five her job of resigned that simply
this should be seven coming all da porn
depending on what why does is moving
next so the first win for Gelfand in
this tournament and really deserved when
I must say he came up with a really good
innovation in the opening with b6 which
I think should travel white I mean I
cannot really see someone repeating this
as white because it was such a such a
wipeout after like 20 moves black was
already more comfortable and he really
played a kind of model game to take to
take advantage out of those those
weaknesses that white created yeah this
whole line with the pawn weaknesses on
the queenside
maybe looks a bit in doubt now after
after this approach that Gelfand
introduced here with E 5 and B 6 it's
really am looking good for for black
gang I would I would say okay so this
was a good game by Gelfand the other one
that I'd like to show in some more
detail was from Nick against sweet love
of course kramnik he has played seven
drawers now the whole first half of the
tournament was draws but it wasn't
really like a tournament where he didn't
fight or anything he did fight and he
had chances to win games but he didn't
it didn't work out he could easily have
plus two but he also could have easily
had minus 1 if Gelfand yesterday would
have found Knight to g5 I mean what I
found this the wrong the wrong term
after Kramnik blundered with 98
yesterday night g5 was calculated by
Gelfand that's not not a movie you you
need to find in a way everybody's
that is dangerous he miscalculated
somehow and ramnik slipped out of this
he could have easily lost the game okay
so seven drawers and one and a half
point behind the leader so you need to
win them with white so sweedler played
the groom fraud of course is his main
opening for all his life against default
I was actually a bit surprised that he
that he did this but okay I think you
probably you need to stick to your guns
but he has lost and the groom fell so
often against Kramnik I don't know I
just felt that he would he would do
something else but okay we get a
mainline and kramnik place the Bishop
III line Knight f3 Bishop III this is
one of the lines that he has played
regularly over the years in fact it was
the line that he used in the second game
of the 2012 championship match which was
played in London actually against
Kasparov and he used this to win the
second game and this really somewhat
upset Kasparov he had prepared the green
felt for the match and he lost the first
green fought against this line okay
continued Queen a5 attacking this pawn
so Queen d2 makes sense not the only
Muslim but certainly the normal 196
whoopsy won and now takes this is some
the most popular option actually against
which would be three going to this end
game where White has a good center which
looks looks comfortable but he's got one
problem the king is in the center of
course they continued castles d5
immediately kicking the night and now
rook ta this has been played for more
than 100 times actually in my database
Oh am i confusing something but it has
played really lots of times lots of
times and the amazing thing is here
Kramnik played without much hesitation
the move King to see - and this is not a
novelty I actually found one game in my
database at least with this move from
the early 80s um a game between I think
two international masters from East
Germany if I'm not mistaken I hope I
don't I don't get it totally wrong but
it wasn't like a super top top ten game
or something so Queen so King King - see
- and it looks like a weird move if you
ask me it blocks the the C file and what
is the King exactly doing on C to the
normal moopheus King e1 and one thing
that I need to show is the continuation
after King e1 the main movie is Knight
to f5 it is known that this isn't so
great because white can take and get
rather big space advantage maybe a first
Bishop c4 and then a four but it's it's
this kind of position this is why oops
after King e1 they play this move and
now an important point is white very
often plays Bishop g5 here attacking the
pawn and in fact black can't ignore this
he plays very often in this position
Bishop to d7
just keep this position in mind the idea
after taking is rupee eight d6 knight c6
and at the end there's a for falling
yeah in the game Kramnik played this
move and if you now continue in the same
fashion Knight a5 Bishop g5 Bishop b7
just the same moves then white can
actually take him it's a different thing
because after you create white has
Bishop before and in the other position
with the king only one there would be
rook takes e4 with a check just winning
this piece on before of course there's
no check iam this means that black has a
problem he cannot simply take only form
in fact a fun thing is this line but
black he has the very truth Knight c4
which is of course impossible to see
beforehand when you yeah maybe not
impossible but it's it's really
difficult the ideas after Bishop takes
this rupee em and now this these bishops
are skewered night hears answered by
Bishop h6 and really you cannot you
cannot save your bishops you will lose
one of them back and black has equalized
him easily even it's um it's a good
equality nothing to worry about
this is one idea of from next move not
the only one but this is one idea for me
sweedler was surprised obviously mean
and understandably it's it's basically a
novelty and he went Knight to e5 after
long thought and I'm pretty sure that he
didn't like to play this move because it
leads to to the structure that I
mentioned before with a form that simply
looks better for white I mean white must
have some advantage in this position
simply because of the central dominance
it's a question how much advantage is
this but it's clear that white is
somewhat better and the the worst thing
is that this is the kind of position
that kramnik is playing exceptionally
well maybe better than anyone else in
the world this kind of position with a
central majority where the opponent
doesn't have any play he's simply deadly
in this I was at this point I would have
taken bets that white wins the game
simply because of the player and the
position I mean I like the position I
would have loved to have this but ramnik
is just great in this okay he needed to
move the King out of the C file at some
point so King to b3 + f6 GF e 5 was a
possibility so he stops that and now a
for a typical move you want to prevent
black from getting it active play with
b5 and now I play group c8 h form
typical move intending age 5 to open the
H valve and combine threats on the Queen
side like this with play on the King
side another general idea in this
position is to prepare a 45 was Bishop
d4 for example he 5 would be am a big
progress
why'd ya H forms Willa played rugby
eight and crumbling played Bishop to b5
simple and strong taking on a 7s bed
after Leucadia a form saying black is
even winning in this position cannot
take chronic played played this move and
this some initiates a forced sequence
now black basically needs to take not
much else retakes
and now a six this is also pretty much
force as a seven was saying and of
course cannot play something like this
this is just awful
Roxy six and why dominates completely
just a six and now b6 yeah and this some
position it's also it's it's still a
question how much of an advantage
this really is white is certainly better
but is it something tangible something
that you can word into into into win in
fact here there are more than one
options switch I played King f7
immediately in the analysis room um we
discussed this rook takes c1 rook takes
c1 and King f7 and in fact here I made a
suggestion I'm pretty proud of this I
think it's really a great move rook
everyone and I looked at this afterwards
and the engine actually wants to play
this as well which is always nice to see
the computer yeah telling you that you
actually for once made a good move rook
f1 has the idea to play e5 technically
with the King on f7 and if black plays
something like e six you have a five
because this is a check and this is why
I look everyone is a good idea
and this isn't fair disaster I mean
losing a piece so black would need to
move the bishop now and have this
absolutely awful position look at one
ISM it's a good idea but it didn't
happen
he played King f7 immediately yeah now
chronic played h5 you basically need to
do this after you when the edge voided
it makes sense like exchanged and wide
exchange on on on g6 yeah here um it was
pretty surprising for me at least that
Svidler captured now on g6 with the King
ours basically only expecting him to
take with the pawn but maybe this in
fact was wasn't so great as well king g6
maybe was better after taking with the
porn um it's not easy okay the first
move is is you need to take with the
bishop take with the rook as says it's
completely useless as black will get the
H farm don't want that so taking with
the bishop and now this position is very
interesting you can invest some time to
to analyze this it's really a fine line
between equal play and and white having
ideas all the time what I think still
should be somewhat better but it's
probably um defensible but not at all
easy I can I can put something on the
board let's say let's say here Bishop to
c5 attacking the pawn then a good idea
for why it is simply to go here but
should be to black cannot take of course
this check
this is this is too much you you lose
due to the central pawns and this just
picks up the poor rook on b8 so black
cannot take on b6 you need to do
something else maybe this one to have
rook g7 available but now he five we
should be six and Bishop e3 attacking a7
something like this for example White
has sacrificed upon but he's got very
dangerous play and I'm not I'm not so
sure I think it is probably good for
white still it's not a fast line and
it's just a simple line it feels like
after taking with the pawn black is also
in trouble maybe it was better it's it's
very difficult to say this is also the
the thing why this position is so
uncomfortable Black has got nothing
active he can do it just needs to defend
and white can try numerous ways to
improve the position yeah King takes
bishop takes and now it continues here
in fact it was possible for swindler to
play the move and h5 and maybe this was
a possible improvement after h5 the
ideas if white plays f5 and grabs on h5
there's rook g8 and this is nothing
you'd simply for white I mean to take
this pawn white cannot cannot protect it
and this means black against is
perfectly alright so white probably
shouldn't play even f5 you could go for
foreign improvement or improving move
like like this or something on rook age
form a possibility another idea would be
to play this
and play Bishop III getting rid of the
bishop and then trying to capture but
here like him take playing walk c8 maybe
H 5 H 5 seems tougher to me
he played Luke g8 allowing this G 4 move
and he said to Spiller said in the press
conference that he somehow forgot about
about this idea that one can play G 4
and now it's it's really uncomfortable
age 60 played rook aged 5 and I think
after the next move it's maybe gone and
not really not a tenable position
anymore Bishop c5 seems tougher I mean
still
I would prefer white by by quite quite a
bit margin but it still it's a fight
after this there's something like this
just for argument's sake attacking h6
like covers it and then it simply
continues with white playing something
like this why does a pawn down but it's
it's simply a good position I mean p7 s
not the move that troubles you whether
the the the unit on b7 the pawn it's not
something that troubles you immediately
and whereas white and you have ideas to
push in the center with your pawns you
attack h6 so this is somewhat passive
the rook on h8 it's not clear to me you
would need to analyze this deeper but
this is probably what what black should
have tried what he did in the game seems
to seem so loose basically he played um
let's go back he played King to f7 and
after this wide manage
he 5 and e6 and this is too much
capturing also wouldn't have wouldn't
have helped after this you need to
really go into a passive position here
with the King on f8
kramnik first covered the porn king g7
and f5 m and this is the problem what
are you doing with this porn if black
plays rook to h8 there's a simple idea
of Bishop perform and what now for black
it's really a disaster if you capture
here you've got this this move coming
the ideas if you take now you even have
this option you get a new queen so black
would need to move the king now and
after g5 it's it's simply a disaster
those pawns decide yeah I played rope d8
Bishop h6 with check King back and King
C for easy you need to protect this pawn
it's much more important than p6 of
course yeah black took and now g5 and
this is simply gradient you have those
active pawns advance and they will
guarantee you some passed pawns that
will win the game attacking the rook and
repeat reform simple and strong now just
threatening to take with check King here
and here chromium calculated for a bit
and then played the winning sequence
he took him the simple thing is if black
captures the bishop you simply take and
then this for ports it's a bit much this
will promote
hehe recaptured and now he's have new
probably can also we treat the bishop
and and win but have a look at this for
example if you go here there's first
something to calculate I mean this this
is easy but it's it's maybe not 100%
clear cut this simply wins attacking the
rook gives a check and the two pawns are
simply too much sweeter played this if
he would take here there's d6 and
promoting this also doesn't help
it's a tempo here yeah in the game there
was Bishop c5 and after rook c4 sweetly
resigned as there simply rook c5 coming
and then your pawns are promoting so a
very very nice win here for kramnik in a
very typical fashion I mean this kind of
games he won won a lot with those
advantage in the center and the big pawn
center and at the end there were pawns
pushing through in the center I think of
course there was some better defense
that swindler could have played but I
think the real issue was this early idea
in the opening which now puts would led
to the test in a way where do you go
with your knight Knight e5 leads to a
very one-sided position which is maybe
with great play a draw for black but
it's not fun and it's exactly the
position that Kramnik wanted or you play
Knight a5 and probably he saw some line
after Knight a5 that he didn't like and
he didn't want to go into this more
forcing way to play and knowing that
had analyzed all this at home 95 versus
sort of move that okay and no I'm worse
but I'll try to survive and with the
good defense draw the game night 85 is
the move that says ok I don't really
believe you I think 95 is the best move
anyway so I go for it and I don't mind
that you have all this prepare to move
30 or something yes so it took this
practical decision 95 but at the end he
he lost the game still not 100% clear to
me if he could have defended
successfully be interesting to put in
more time to to to find this out alright
so we had formed four games or let's say
three games and some drove it really was
a bit disappointing to have this clash
of the the two leaders some have this
end so early but it sometimes happens
with great preparation you you would
simply need to acknowledge this in
modern chess it's nothing that you can
do much about
in fact Carles a prime example that you
can play an excellent with excellent
results without this deep computer prep
but it sometimes happens to him he plays
somewhat yeah less inspiring opening
with with maybe not the biggest ideas
behind it that the game Peters out to a
draw he obviously didn't want to risk
anything I mean if he would push hard he
would play I don't know I'd say with
wide the Scotch with some some technical
ideas or whatever and he did do that he
went for some the Catalan which is the
safe choice but very often just ends up
in the drawer yeah thanks for watching
and tomorrow I'll be on again with the
game on kramnik against Carlton which is
very important for the tournament of
course yeah thanks for watching until
tomorrow bye